Darth Vader Reigns Supreme as the
greatest bad guy the Star Wars franchise
has ever seen that being said here are
some franchise villains who are arguably
even scarier and more powerful than
Vader himself when discussing iconic
villains outside of the core Star Wars
movies one has to mention Grand amiral
Thon the stoic chis strategist helped
resurrect Star Wars in the 1990s with
Timothy X's beloved heir to the Empire
novel's jumpstarting interest in the
franchise again and keeping fans
occupied where they waited for the
prequels where is your
master where is Grand Admiral
Thon though he was briefly exposed from
the cannon after Disney took over the
franchise thron returned in Star Wars
Rebels and has become increasingly
important to the modern timeline he's
the primary villain of the liveaction
Ahsoka on Disney plus and for good
reason thron is a truly terrifying
individual sure he may not have the
hulking black suit murderous Force
powers or imposing red lights saber
Darth Vader has but in a way that only
makes him more intimidating aside from
his bright red eyes and cold blue skin
he looks pretty normal but the
unassuming exterior hides one of the
most brilliant and brutal Minds in all
of Star Wars though he occasionally
hesitates before taking innocent lives
thron is usually willing to do anything
necessary to win and his Legend's
Incarnation is even more frightening
than the new Cannon Thon though Disney
still has a lot of places it could take
the character stepping back into the
modern Star Wars cannon we've got the
shadowy leader of the night sisters of
damir mother talzin talzin primarily
appears as a secondary antagonist in
Star Wars the Clone Wars where she AIDS
her children assage Ventress Tage
oppress and mo in their battles against
Dar cidus and K duu she puts a lot of
innocent people in danger through her
dark force schemes of
Conquest I must make the necessary
preparations talin may not be as overtly
intimidating or good in a fight as Darth
Vader or many other characters on this
list however she makes a cut for
slightly different reasons even though
she hasn't attempted to take over the
galactic Senate Earth Force powers are
Beyond almost anything else in the
cannon talin's magical abilities are
never fully explained which is also what
makes them so dangerous throughout the
Clone Wars she demonstrates a Mastery of
the dark arts that allows for full mind
control the ability to cheat death
through spiritual means and the power to
turn other life forms into incredibly
powerful and violent soldiers does cidus
considers her a direct rival and he goes
out of his way to deal with her in the
Clone Wars after her interference in his
plans if you've got sheave knocking on
your front door you know you're doing
something right or well wrong though
villains like Revan and nihilist may be
more famous than the Old Republic fo
Darth Malgus their stories are also more
complicated which is part of their
appeal Malgus on the other hand is a
villain in every sense of the
word finally we have returned a brutal
tactician and Fierce and Warrior Malgus
wrote The Playbook Darth Vader uses when
he sacks the Jedi Temple at the end of
the Clone Wars Malgus takes over the
stronghold several thousand years
earlier wiping out numerous Jedi Masters
and effectively shattering the order
Malgus was a force in the Galaxy for
years putting Jedi and fellow Sith alike
in their place and establishing himself
as a dark force Boogeyman plus just look
at the guy he's terrifying some of the
characters on this list are beings of
pure dark force energy leaders of
powerful military Legions and ruthless
murderers Dagen Gara is none of those
things he's a former Jedi whose
Obsession and ego lead him down a dark
path eventually foregoing everything and
everyone he once claimed to fight for
how arrogant that you would presume to
know what drives me when you first meet
dag and Gara in Star Wars Jedi Survivor
It's Not Unusual to just feel bad for
the guy during the high Republic era
hundreds of years before the original
Star Wars Trilogy dagam was one of of
the order's most powerful and respected
knights in the time since he was put
into stasis the entire Jedi Order was
destroyed however these initial feelings
of sympathy are quickly replaced by fear
dagger may not have the warlord Persona
of Darth Vader but it's hard to watch
him in motion and not feel unnerved he
looks walks and talks like a ghost a
clear reflection of his status as a man
out of time his icy eyes and cold
determined energy are imposing to say
the least and thus without even getting
into dagon's power as a fighter he put P
es cestus to his limit with only one arm
and his skill at projecting Illusions
through the force is beyond anything
previously seen in the cannon the dark
side is more than just a cool goth
aesthetic but nobody told the Sun that
he's also crazy powerful as one of the
three force wielders of mortis also
known simply as the ones a sun is an
ancient being of immense power whose
very essence is intrinsically connected
to the force and while his sister got to
be part of the Light Side the sun
through no choice of his own was stuck
with the D
how simple you make it light and dark as
if there is one without the other the
mortis Arc of Star Wars C Clone Wars
shows just how terrifying the sun can be
not only is he an incredibly powerful
force user in his own right capable of
high level combat abilities and full-on
transformation into a massive beast but
he can take over the minds of other
people and twist them toward the dark
his father suggests that the sun
escaping from morttis could Doom the
entire galaxy fortunately Le Anakin
Obi-Wan and Ahsoka Tano managed to stop
the sun before that happens Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic 2 the Sith
Lords introduced several great
characters including the dark Sith Lord
Darth trer and there must always be a
Darth
tryer the Galaxy needs its betrayers
what sets trer apart from the other Sith
on this list and even more from a
one-time allies Darth Zion and Darth NIS
is her utter disdain for the force
itself trya views the force as a God of
sorts one that forces its will on every
being in the Galaxy trapping them in its
Eternal plan for this reason she wants
to free the Galaxy from its influence
something that no other villain in all
of Star Wars has ever attempted the
sheer scale of treer scheme puts her in
a class by herself a harbinger of
Destruction who truly believes that her
way is the best for the Galaxy would be
remissed to not include a villain from
the Star Wars High Republic era on this
list and the obvious choice is martian
Row the leader of the deadly Marauder
band known as denal marro is directly
responsible for causing the so-called
great hyperspace disaster which kicks
off the high Republic Ark and leads to
widespread destruction and death across
the Galaxy though he's ostensibly just a
pirate Ro devises a plan that puts the
Jedi on the back foot his most
terrifying weapons are the nameless
ruthless monsters who hunt down anyone
strong in the force quite literally
boogey men for the Jedi the nameless are
used to Great effects during Martian
Rose's Conquest he can't force choke you
or shoot lightning out of his hands but
he shows is just how powerful someone
can become simply through strategy
determination and fear BR causes more
chaos than most Sith Lords ever have
earning him an easy spot on this list in
both Legends and the modern Star Wars
cannon Darth Bane is the creator of the
rule of two the Sith doctrine that
dictates there can only be one master
and one Apprentice of the order at any
given time roughly a thousand years
before the prequels the Sith were wiped
out by a combination of their war with
the Jedi constant infighting and Bain's
efforts to eradicate the them from
within prior to Bane instit using the
rule of two the Sith through a sprawling
order much like the Jedi he believed
that the only way for them to be strong
enough to survive was to consolidate
power in as few people as possible the
rule was designed from the beginning
with this goal in mind a master to wield
the full brunt of the dark side and an
apprentice to keep the master on their
toes the inherence tension between the
two would ensure that the most powerful
person possible would always be on top
his importance to the history of Star
Wars is enough to land him on a list of
notable villains but Bane is
intimidating enough in his own right to
earn a spot here plenty of Sith have
wiped out innocence and Jedi but Bane
seemingly wiped out the rest of the Sith
proving himself a True Villain among
villains born Jason solo the son of Hann
and Leia Darth cadis is one of the most
famous and Powerful villains in the
Legends timeline he fights valiantly in
the yuzan bong War but never truly
recovers from the loss of his younger
brother Anakin Solo or the torture he
suffers during the war Jason's fall to
the dark side is one of the longest most
fully developed story lines in the
entire expanded universe culminating in
a tragic climax Darth cadus is downright
terrifying and one of the most powerful
force users in all of Star Wars few
characters are ever able to match him in
a lightsaber D and even his Uncle Luke
Skywalker at the height of his powers
struggles immensely to defeat him his
Force powers are among the most
outrageous in the history of the
franchise cadis learns to ignore all
pain and at one point even becomes one
with the force while still alive Darth
crate certainly isn't the most famous
villain from the Star Wars Legends
timeline but in a way he's the most
important villain in the entire expanded
universe crate's Journey starts away so
many Sith stories do being trained as a
Jedi under his birth name of ashad het
he was a young member of the order join
the prequel era and forc alongside
Anakin Skywalker in the Clone Wars but
it's not until decades later that he
becomes a proper player in the story a
series of Sith encounters and brutal
clashes with the yuzan vong lead crate
down a path to the dark side he becomes
the leader of a secret Sith sect briefly
emerges to help Luke Skywalker defeat
abalo and then goes back into hiding
through various bouts of stasis and the
literal death and Resurrection Arc crate
lives far into the future eventually
Crossing lightsabers with Luke and
Anakin's distant descendant Kate
Skywalker join the Star Wars legacy
series beyond all that crat is a true
Master of the force and one of the main
reasons that Jason solo turns to the
dark side even Luke Skywalker comes to
fear the so-called dark man it's kind of
cheating to put two different characters
in the same spot on this list but
there's a good reason for it to be
honest a yuzan vong as a whole species
could have their own ranking here in the
entirety of Star Wars there may not be a
more horrifying foe but in the interest
of keeping things specific we're
focusing on two particular yusan bang
shimad Germain the Supreme Overlord
during the yuzan bong war and anomy
who's pulling the strings of the war
from the shadows in a away these two
characters are the same shimura is the
face and anomy is the mind the plan to
invade the star Galaxy and assimilator
into the vong's distorted biohacked
hellscape comes from anomy and the many
warriors of these zealous conquerors put
it into practice the yuzan vong war is a
single most devastating event in the
expanded universe wiping out countless
lives and numerous beloved characters
including chewbaca and Anakin solo the
vong are horrifying to look at they use
torture as a standard method of breaking
and corrupting prisoners and with only a
couple of exceptions like anomy they
have absolutely zero connection to the
force and no to vonger More Scary or
powerful than anami and Shamara
[Music]
Jermain